j'avais un rêve j'ai travaillé toute ma
vie dans les énergies renouvelables et
dans l'eau avec vernier donc il marche
très bien je suis toujours dans vergnet
hydro conception et j'ai voulu réunir
les deux parce que l'humanité va manquer
d'aborder la moitié de l'humanité n'aura
pas d'autres en 2030 c'est c'est
incroyablement important et donc
pourquoi ne pas utiliser cette énergie
renouvelable pour dessaler de l'eau de
mer dessalée de ce matin donc c'est le
pari que nous avons pris avec une petite
équipe à chartes et nous avons trouvé
nous sommes les premiers au monde à
avoir un système qui fonctionne à
l'énergie solaire avec vernis hydro nous
venons d'avoir un appel d'offres pour
six machines qui vont alimenter des
petits villages
donc il ya là quelque chose de famille
et je crois que quand on a ça dans le
sang on continue inventer innover et
c'est ce que je voudrais donner comme
message aux repreneurs qu'il met à la
tête de l'entreprise
un entrepreneur est pas un gestionnaire
est quelqu'un qui est qui et les tripes
industriel parce qu'on ne réussit pas
une pme sans la vivre de l'intérieur
avec une compétence industrielle